first up talking about a big fan I love
this guy the actor and comedy legend who
started city slickers analyzed this When
Harry Met Sally his memoir still fooling
him is now in paperback mister Saturday
night here on a Friday Billy Crystal
[Applause]
standing on all places no no but look
there's so much bad stuff in the news
that I said you know usually I'm talking
to an expert about it I said no I want
Billy Crystal good time and you know
first thing I want to talk about is I
know you tore like I do and I have been
in restaurants where people have guns
it's like Texas not just Texas but yeah
that's one state where I mean I've seen
it in lots of places and what you really
realized that we live in a little bubble
out here wouldn't you say that oh yeah I
was I did this tour and it was great but
San Antonio Houston there's guns in the
audience yes I thought cell phones were
a problem right that's a heckle would
you seem on the coat rack in a
restaurant you see people with holsters
I'm in the back of a truck yeah they're
very well behaved waiters though I have
to say but it's but it's it's um it's
the culture that we have and it's it's
we love our guns yeah that's the problem
that's a problem it's this psychology I
agree and it's yeah the language of guns
is in our culture what do we want from a
politician who want a straight shooter
oh look at her she's half cocked
you know if the song is a hit it's it's
number ten with a bullet a bullet yeah
alright watch a football game it's all
guns they're in a shotgun offense right
you know he's got a rifle for an arm
he's got a lot of weapons in his arsenal
yeah he looks downfield he's got the
receiver in his sights he hit someone to
bullet right in the Jess
it's all its own
[Music]
and this horrible thing about well we
want we don't want to talk about it now
it's not the time to talk right never
when it happens
I don't understand I don't know of
course no it's ridiculous I mean when is
the right time I mean we have another
hurricane heading away what are we going
to talk about that when is Scott Pruett
gonna realize that he's the head of the
Environmental Protection Agency plus
33,000 jobs we had the worst job report
in seven years because of the hurricanes
so you'd think the party of business
would get that in their head you know
one thing that might ring a bell no no
bill this is a huge bail turing yeah you
know this is a real this is a real guy
when you're in places like that i always
say this i'm curious if you find the
same thing the i like the audience is
even better
yeah in a red state they are more
surprised to see me
i don't know about you because you're
you know you appeal to everybody I don't
have that I don't have that but no I
mean you know the Conservatives don't
come up but there are liberal people in
red states and I find audiences are
different in the Trump era yeah it's a
lot more shouting out supportively but
they're just they are crazy yeah there's
a little crazy it feels like wrestling
it feels like Trump feels like Vince
McMahon from the beginning we're gonna
show up Thursday right I don't you know
this that kind of stuff there's any
awful it's just awful he's so I was on
stage and they're very emboldened to say
they love to yell at you that's yeah so
I don't do a lot of political stuff but
I stumbled into a really funny thing I
was talking about my old friend Howard
Cosell oh and I had known Howard for
years you know Howard Cosell
and one year one year how Woodward voted
the most loved than the most hated man
on television in the same poll so he's
very similar to the guy running the show
right now yeah you know love hate love
hate and so I start I said you know I
loved him because he was smart he was
outspoken he was brazen he had contempt
for society and he just as he would say
I told it like it is in sports yeah but
wouldn't it be great covering the White
House yeah there's a guy I want so I
started riffing on it let's take a look
at this cabinet up close and personal
this is the cabinet abducted caller Gary
if I've ever seen it let's start with
Betsy demas education once it oh one
should actually have an education before
you get that job and there's Vice
President Mike Pence this guy looks like
one of the men who chased the Von Trapp
family into the al
[Applause]
so I'm scoring left's and rights right
so I finish the thing and you know you
finish a big hunka tits then it settles
and you move on to your next thing out
of the dark a woman yells at me
honor the president Oh crowd boos they
boo
and I went folks I'll handle this I went
to college for this let me do this so
what does it man honor the president she
won't stop so I said what listen when he
honors all Americans then I'll honor him
big applause from the audience right
honor the president she won't stop now
you feel like you could lose the show so
I said to her listen I appreciate that
you love this man I appreciate that I
respect that so I'm gonna use his own
words on you get her out
[Applause]
I have trouble being that nice to a
trump supporter like that because he's
so insensitive but of course it bothered
me that he got elected it bothered me
more that so many people in this country
would vote for somebody so vulgar I know
it who's been so rotten to so many
people in such a personal way he is the
most I mean what is your favorite
insensitivity of Donald Trump there's so
many to choose well oh well it's when he
doesn't say something that's also awful
I mean the the the all the comments
about from the beginning of the debate I
hated the taunting the the little Marco
yeah I don't you know now the little
rocket man I hate that I wasn't I'm not
a big guy so when everyone taunt me I
don't like it but you know this guy's
got missiles right yeah just shut the
[ __ ] up
but Holocaust Remembrance Day he doesn't
mention the Jews right if any there's if
any there's a day to mention the Jews
rights Holocaust Remembrance Day then
when a march in in Charlottesville and
his screaming the Jews will not replace
his Jews are not replaces he's the
grandfather of Orthodox Jewish children
sure his son-in-law who he loves openly
as an Orthodox Jew his daughter who he
loves suspiciously
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's a Friday night yeah he doesn't say
anything he doesn't say anything except
there's some very fine people some very
fine people were yelling the Jews or not
replaces yeah and that's what you just
if there was a God Joe Lieberman would
be vice president too when this schmuck
is impeach the Jew would replace him
[Music]
I had a show a few weeks ago with Salman
Rushdie and I saw Tim Gunn and then
friend Leibowitz is here and and it's
for people over 60 and we got to talking
about a because I said this doesn't
often happen on TV and I thought you're
coming on you and I are both now rapidly
approaching 40 and my IMDB page and said
that they laugh so quickly and yeah but
it sort of is the last group of people
you can [ __ ] on in America isn't it I
mean there's every sort of shaming yeah
slut-shaming and victim-blaming and fat
shaming and but if anybody screws up
who's even our age or older immediately
you go to not an individual well what do
you want he's 80 yeah you know Clint
Eastwood's 85 and Woody Allen's 80
something until making movies yeah I
feel it's individual but what do you
think well I'm gonna be 70 and feel
pretty good that that bothers me it but
it's just I hate that oh you're still
alive
[Applause]
when you say I've been married 20 years
that's a miracle I've been married
almost 48 years that's a real you know I
I talked about it on the UH non in my
show because that's that's where I'm at
now I'm I can't talk about dating right
no yeah hey your oxygen of mine you know
I can't do that want to see some spider
veins you know but that's the way it is
and and it's it but it gives me I think
a little perspective that I didn't have
like there are things that I know I
would not do now that I might have done
early and things pissed me off more I'm
becoming you know the guy in your
neighborhood don't hit it into old-man
crystals yard you're not gonna get that
ball back you know did I earn you're
cranky you know what I was really crying
embracive Sean Spicer at the Emmys piss
me off big time
perfect right all people we know taking
selfies with him in the green room
afterwards embracing him kissing his
cheek right this guy this half man/half
Jack Russell Terrier was the liar was
the was the was the was the voice for
this crap you know I mean Hitler didn't
use poison gas on his own people even
Mel Gibson said I go vote what an
[ __ ]
but you know so forgets I would never
embrace that it's and so would that
really turned me off well I hope you
keep getting pissed off well I because
we have a right because it creates
comedy yeah so and but but you know what
else bill I know we got to go soon
because I saw the three Horsemen of the
Apocalypse
this this is like doing the voice so
they gonna like turn around and look at
being going the one thing that is really
important about the age I'm at and about
where we're heading as a country that I
feel really important about is I have
four grandchildren and they're 14 11
soon to be 8 and for what world are we
giving them what we am I gonna you know
help them live in what world are we
gonna do that and we're gonna have
enough fish are we gonna have enough air
we're gonna have enough water we're
gonna have people who believe in science
so we can maybe turn this around what
what kind of world am i leaving it
that's what at this age I think about
more than anything unfortunately a world
where all those questions are open great
to end on a down note
[Laughter]
[Applause]